hey everyone uh can you hear me okay in
the back good awesome so like she said
I'm Kevin Oreca I currently am believe
data scientists at Walmart technology
that's down the road but in a lot of my
free time I work with Austin pets alive
and American pets alive which are down
what direction Cesar Chavez and I've
been volunteering there since about 2011
and have noticed all sorts of different
opportunities to try to use different
advanced technologies that they aren't
aware of and even actually basic
technologies that they're not aware of
in order to help them with their mission
which is to save all pets that are being
needlessly killed so there's a lot that
goes into you know their definition
their mission those sorts of things how
is this thing not working okay
there's can't take that off there's a
lot of things that go into this mission
and I don't have time unfortunately to
tell you all about what they're doing
and all the cool things that they're
doing so instead what I decided I'd do
is pick out the three sort of most
advanced case studies that I've done
with them
to apply these advanced technologies to
help them with their mission which is
effectively to save as many animals as
they can so there are three takeaways or
four takeaways rather that I want you to
sort of get out of this talk and none of
them have to do with the details of the
case study I think there's a lot of cool
engineering and technology that you're
gonna see scattered throughout this talk
but actually my pitch to you is it has
nothing to do with the technology it has
to do with your skills so most of the
people in this room probably do have
some interesting skills we all very
varied skills and the sort of thing I
want to emphasize out of this talk is
that you have skills that you can use to
help nonprofits and that is probably the
most satisfying thing you could do with
your free time and I've absolutely loved
doing it over the past eight years or so
so the the challenge here is that the
nonprofit's really have no idea anything
about technology like we're talking they
don't know Google Forms exists and so
like they need you to go to them they
can't advertise for what they need
because they don't know what they need
because they don't know what's possible
so that's a huge part and and you know
it comes along with that is that helping
them is actually very hard and it often
requires you to spend a lot of time with
them trying to understand them because
they can't spend time with you
understanding you they're already
strapped for resources and really need
you to work on their terms not the other
way around which i think is why
engineering isn't as pervasive and a lot
of nonprofits as it could be they're
you're gonna find the moment you go to
basically any nonprofit that doesn't
already have engineering people there
are a million cool things that problems
that you can solve for them and the
reason I think that you're not seeing
more of that in sort of a public eye is
simply because they're so busy they
can't reach out that makes sort of it
cool that you can get in there and
immediately make impact so that's an
exciting thing to be able to do for an
organization literally give them the
simplest technology you're just like
gonna be like how could they not know
that this exists but this the thing that
you give them is gonna be incredibly
valuable so it's it's simultaneously
very hard to work with and very easy to
solve their problems for the most part
but lastly because they don't have sort
of domain experts in in engineering you
really need to be careful what
technologies you give them for a variety
of reasons we don't have time to go over
here one of the reasons I'm gonna
emphasize though when it comes to really
advanced technologies is that they don't
understand a lot about like data science
and modeling and they may not think of
the unethical uses of models so for
instance you come up with a really good
model that predicts some aspect of their
process they may have competitor
organizations that if you Pupp make that
model public we'll use that to do the
opposite of their mission because all of
these models are double-edged swords
depending on who you're talking to so
this is really what I want you to get
out of the talk the details that I'm
gonna go into I think are really
interesting and I hope you enjoy them
but I think there's a lot more
opportunity for us as engineers to help
out these nonprofits
if you're specifically interested in
animal sheltering that link there which
hopefully you can see later links to a
article that I published a week or two
ago on all of the problems that animal
shelters are facing just kind of
stimulate ideas on if you know any
technologies that might apply to those
problems you might be able to
participate in that setting okay so this
talk we're gonna go over a three case
studies one on a disease called parvo
and some of the health economics work
that I've done in that space one on
distemper and some disease simulation
spread if you've been to our data ontap
events you've probably seen a lot of
this content you won't have seen this
third one which is developing
dashboarding and other technologies
around kpi's top level measurements of
success for these shelters in a way that
can can solve issues with tracking how
well animal shelters are doing because
believe it or not we don't actually know
how many animals are being saved or not
in the US
I'm also gonna try to do this thing
where I'm gonna put any tools that I use
or their logos up in that corner so if
you're curious how I did something you
can kind of look up into that corner and
get a sense of what what tools were
being used
so for parvo the goal here with parvo is
part parvo is this highly deadly
infectious disease it's an intestinal
virus it kills over 90% of the animals
that it infects if you treat it you can
save 90% of them so totally flip it on
its head it's is really only killable by
bleach and unfortunately lives in the
environment for over a year so if a dog
with parvo goes to a dog park then that
dog park has parvo for at least a year
assuming no other dogs go there and
you're not gonna bleach the grass so it
just is and there are places that they
actually will go through and completely
tabula rasa the the field but that's not
as common so it's Vick Otis and the
environments it'll end up killing the
animal from dehydration and secondary
infections so you can just treat it by
giving them fluids and antibiotics so
we're already doing this and it'll
resolve within a week or two and it's
kind of like chickenpox you won't get it
again your if you have an animal you
don't need to worry about this because
you probably got them vaccinated
hopefully you got them vaccinated if
they're vaccinated for it they're good
to go so these aren't risk for any dogs
except for ones that haven't been known
before and therefore haven't been
vaccinated so the things that we'd like
to be able to do in the space are
convince others to treat this disease
because believe it or not most people
just kill them the moment that they have
it and sorry if this is a little hard to
read you don't none of the stuff in here
is super important you we want to be
able to optimize the treatment so that
people can not just treat it but treated
cheaply and we want to save the 10% of
animals that were not saving within this
space the key strategy here as you can
imagine from my pitch at the beginning
is that we've really got to get into the
the shelters understand the stakeholders
needs and save them time with tools so
that then we can get the data we need to
actually try to answer these questions
because they don't have that data and
they don't have the capability to
collect it upfront and so the the
strategy that I used in this project
which spanned many years was to
basically try to save them time so that
I could get the things I needed to try
to work on these problems so the first
step in saving time for me was to build
them some tools I built them into shift
reports dashboards some document
scanning literally to show them how to
use Google Drive to scan documents
process documentation so
keye that describes what they need to do
for things then once I provided that
value I asked them for some follow-up
help try to get things like how many
animals are coming through with the
disease how many volunteers are being
used to treat them because actually
Austin pets alive has the largest parvo
treatment ICU in the world we treat more
animals per year than we're used to
validate that the test for parvo works
so that we're talking order of magnitude
more animals than anyone else sees with
parvo in the entire world so how long
are the shifts taking what what are they
actually treating them how are the vets
behaving towards these animals what are
the demographics and outcomes and then
you can use this data to provide more
value that then lets you get into this
cycle of sort of success where you're
starting to give them insights give the
the shelter insights that they can take
home and use things like dashboards and
analytics things like predicting
outcomes analysis of risks which I'll
show you a few these things and some
demographic distribution information as
well as things like resource allocation
which they don't know you know how much
time and money is going into these
things a lot of time and that's a really
critical fact if you're gonna try and
pitch other organizations to do the same
things that they're doing so starting
off take the Google strategy because
they are to use a lot of Google tools
Gmail and Google Groups give them things
like better data tracking easier you
know printing of their sheets and
dashboards give them all these tools
teach them to use the tools on their
terms
so don't sort of force the tools in I
actually may probably double this amount
of tools and the other have failed
because they just weren't working for
them so sometimes you've got to kind of
throw a lot of different options at them
and see which ones work out best for
them and then once you've done that
you've you've gotten this sort of
upfront investment in these two fields
which then allows you to answer
questions to try to get other people to
actually treat these diseases so the
first question that that we wanted to
ask was just how much does it cost turns
out it cost fifty six dollars and you
can see that that's the mean the medians
to the left of that and that that cost
is primarily driven by the cost of
medications and so larger dogs need more
medication because medication is dose by
weight and so the result was that we can
give advice to other shelters who want
to treat this that you should start off
with your lighter weight dogs lighter
weight dogs have a higher risk of dying
but you can kind of pick pick and choose
your populations if you need to for cost
reasons and understand your expectation
should be 56 dollars then you can
continue and say well
okay within that population what are the
expensive things we do what are the
cheap things we do those are the
medications that they give on the top
that big sharp bar there is actually an
anti-nausea medication it turns out you
can actually treat parvo without that so
if you eliminate that bar you can cut
your cost in half because that bar
actually is bigger than the sum of all
the other bars and so that's another
piece of advice you can give to other
organizations that we didn't know up
front we know is expensive we didn't
know is that expensive and that if you
take it away you have your costs another
thing to note is that really lightweight
animals have a really poor chance of
survival up front and so shelters may
need to adapt their practices as a APA
has for those animals we actually place
IVs immediately upon arrival and those
animals to increase their chances which
is something we started in the past year
or so on the economics fronts for the
human resources APA is a largely
volunteer run organization and so the
question was how many volunteer hours
are going into these animals as well
because then another organization who
wants to treat them needs to get back
many volunteers in order to treat that
many animals it turns out it takes about
nine volunteer hours to treat one animal
so that's this plot on the top is number
of animals versus number of hours and
you get a roughly linear trend is
actually it fits a little bit better if
you do like a log trend which actually
is kind of a nice thing because it means
they're probably being more efficient
the more animals there are but then if
you look at things like how we're load
balancing staff which is this bottom
plot so it's that top plot but then you
add how many people were on shift at a
given time you'd hope that this thing
would be flat which would mean that
you're you're optimizing the number of
people on the shift that is not the case
and so that means that we actually
probably need more volunteers at APA so
if you want to learn to give injections
and do stuff like that you should
probably reach out and volunteer the
parvo ICU so that was it on the the
health economics front there's a ton
more stuff I'd love to tell you about
but I've got two other case studies to
get to so we're gonna move on when it
comes to things like how to save that
last 10% we really want to address some
of these reasons why we think the
treatment might fail so we think that
maybe they're arriving too late at the
shelter maybe they're catching other
diseases like the one I'm going to talk
about in the second case study the
treatment just might not be effective
for some reason we haven't really
studied the treatment enough to know why
it might fail and then we also know that
there's only volunteers in there for a
little less than 50% of the time
throughout the day because you know
there's a lot of night time where
there's no volunteer there and the
really critical animals will crash
during that time meaning that their
vitals just start to
terrible and then they'll die while no
one's there and so we have protocols on
what to do and when we're there and that
happens we tend to be able to pull them
back they don't always survive at that
point but they may get like a 50% better
chance of surviving at that point and so
being able to detect when that happens
and help and intervene would be I think
a way to increase those numbers so one
of the key things then in trying to get
a sense of that is to get a better sense
of when they're at risk what the
progression of the disease looks like
these are all sort of unstudied things
at for the most part and we do actually
have a measure a direct measure of risk
whenever you go in and treat one of
these animals you pick one of these
bottom four statuses they're either
bright and responsive which is a normal
puppy because it's mostly a puppy
disease they're quiet and responsive you
know they aren't bright but they're not
you know lethargic or comatose which are
the other two and you can look across
time for the whole population how this
sort of progresses and you see they sort
of come in fairly critical and then they
have a flat period where they're still
recovering from the disease and then
they start to improve as a population so
that's sort of the time course we expect
obviously there's some variability here
because they get to us at different
points in time but even just from this
really naive score you can get a sense
of how those eases progression across
the whole population you can also see
those lines that are going straight up
to the top that top line is deceased so
you can see where they're dying in this
plot which is basically in those first
couple days of treatment so we really
need to understand what to do during
their first couple days you can take
this a little farther and this is a fun
thing to play with if you're ever doing
risk analysis you can use things like a
Cox proportionate hazard model which is
a model that makes some assumptions
about the exponential nature of the the
risk of an event occurring at any given
moment in time and you can actually
create a score of risk using a model
like this using a variety of variables
so in this case we use that score from
the previous slide but also things like
what color are their gums which is a
subjective thing a volunteer goes in
there and says are they pink are they
pale pink are they white white is bad
means they have very low circulation you
know are they throwing up what's their
sex which turns out to matter and we
found that a couple different times
still don't really know what's going on
with that and what's their pot
temperature if their paws are cold they
also have bad circulation and you can
throw those things into it one of these
hazard models by giving it a time series
of these variables as they're measured
on the treatment charts which are
already being logged every day
and you can then get sort of a
regression variable that map's how much
how at risk given those variables are
they of hitting the critical event of
dying so many the animals are never
going to hit that critical event but you
can still use their data some of them
will and when they do you can sort of
look backwards at what the the variables
look like and create a an exponential
regression leading up to that event when
you do that you get the plot like this
red and green one over here on the side
the red ones are ones that ended up
dying you can see there's a lot of
variability and they're already higher
than the green dogs which are the ones
that survived these are ones that were
matched for how long they stayed in the
ICU so that that's gonna create a lot of
bias he's actually um so not not the
like best canonical comparison and then
you can look at the relative importance
of those different variables so that
people can take that into account in
trying to understand this score you can
also take all of that data and that
score and try to make different
supervised modeling approaches to say
are they gonna die or not that's really
what we want to know right at any given
time point are they gonna die because if
the answer is yes that means they are
gonna die within the context of the
treatment we're giving them and so we
can maybe give them a new treatment we
can do something experimental if you've
heard of fecal transplants in humans
that's a kind of popular thing to pop up
in the news that's actually an
experimental treatment for parvo as well
you literally get the poop from another
dog put it in a blender put it in the
other dog and apparently that works
really well I'm not a vet so I couldn't
tell you why but doing this problem a
prediction is actually it's it's
interesting because if you give the
model say for treatments worth of data
which is two full days of data that is
enough to do a really good job of
predicting the outcome you can you can
hit nearly a hundred percent within the
data set that I have it's a small data
set so don't trust the results too much
two treatments pretty hard one treatment
virtually impossible so this is the
confusion matrix for one treatment this
is the best I was able to do if you take
a single treatment and try to predict
death from it and it doesn't matter
which treatment but I I did the models
with the first treatment because really
that's what we want the moment they come
in we want to assess them once then we
want to know the answer when once I
built all this stuff I really wanted to
get a sense of how it was working so I
deployed the the Cox proportion it has
her model to a little UI that the vets
can use and go in and just say like I
think this dog is not gonna make it
let's see what the model thinks and I
got some some feedback from them on
whether and
match their intuition very anecdotal
feedback so not something that I want to
trust yet but we're collecting data all
the time to improve these models their
feedback was actually really positive
they felt like once some a dog had about
30 on this score system they were pretty
critical once they had a hundred they
were likely not to survive and then the
data actually says once they hit 300
they won't survive so it gives you a
little bit of a sense of the utility
that these things could bring the last
bit which I think is one of my favourite
pieces of this and still a work in
progress is doing some computer vision
to try to put a low-cost Raspberry Pi
camera on these dogs and track their
respiration and look for that crashing
signal so that you can actually send out
an email to get someone to come in and
do the crashing protocol on them and so
this is a video of the algorithm that I
wrote to do that uses a combination of
computer vision techniques PCA and a
couple other things and you can isolate
regions of the body of the animal where
respiration motion is occurring you can
then crop the image to that and run your
algorithm on it in real time on a
Raspberry Pi so that's a kind of nice
potential approach the reason why this
isn't happening right now in the ICU is
because I don't have a good data set on
sleeping and or crashing animals to
validate the model on so that's the next
step that I'm working on right now on
this but a lot of interesting things you
can do in this space I do want to take a
moment here at the end of this
particular case study to note what would
happen if I succeeded in making a model
that predicted on the first treatment
and then release that model to the world
the vast majority of people as I
mentioned at the beginning of this
section do not treat parvo and in fact
kill the animal the moment they even
think they have parvo they don't even
have to test positive if they're showing
symptoms they'll just kill them and
they'll actually often kill all the
animals around them - sometimes the some
shelters in the extreme cases will wipe
their population those kill everyone
because it's just not worth their risk
to them because of how infectious it is
so releasing a model that would allow
someone to say this animal is not going
to survive a treatment of parvo
therefore we should kill them is
probably my biggest fear of any model I
would ever build that someone would use
my model to decide when to kill
something so I would never release this
model right now even if I got it working
and I think it's an open question in
these spaces where there's sort of a
desperate need for people to understand
what's going on and they're not all
unified in their ethics as to win and
how you should release these models
safely so that's just something on it
bring up because I think it's a
complication even if you succeed have
you really succeeded okay moving on to
number two
so there's another disease and it
happens a lot in that part of ICU called
canine distemper this is often times
when I was talking about sort of another
disease that kills a parvo dog this is
usually the other disease distemper is
an airborne virus so it's very different
from parvo it does not survive out in
the environment very long but it's
incredibly infectious within sort of
about 20 foot radius around animals
about 15% will survive without treatment
so a little better than parvo but still
not good it also has the side effect of
causing neurological dysfunction for
there probably several years after and
potentially the rest of their lives
after they'll have really bad twitching
it often prevents them from sleeping so
you have to give them sedatives all the
time because they're constantly
twitching and so we really want to
prevent them from ever getting this
disease more than we want to treat it
because treatment is is a somewhat
effective eighty percent survival rate
but even if they survive they have these
long-term side effects so it does
typically occur in these small numbers
of populations and the real issues when
there's an outbreak so one animal comes
in with it and then suddenly a bunch of
animals have it you once again your
animals are vaccinated for this if you
have an animal so you shouldn't have to
worry about this but within populations
that aren't yet vaccinated it's a real
problem the way that shelters who try to
combat this rather than killing the
animals try to combat it is by having an
intake area it's a hold area because the
vaccine actually takes about 72 hours to
become about 90% effective and once it's
effective you can effect you can put the
animals in the general population
without a whole lot of worry about them
spreading the disease so they create
this 72-hour holding area where the
animals can be placed temporarily until
their vaccination status becomes known
and then they can go out into the
population that seems to work pretty
well to prevent these outbreaks the
issue becomes when you have like a
rolling outbreak within that intake area
where it just seems to bounce from
animal to animal as animals get released
and then as new animals come in and the
new animals catch it immediately and so
they need a way to sort of break these
rolling outbreaks that can occur in
these intake areas so that was the main
question there's some complications
there's virtually no data to address
things about the spread of this disease
there's really not an inexpensive and
reliable test for the disease so it's
not like can go in and test the animals
see if they have it on intake it costs a
couple hundred dollars to do that and if
you did that on every animal you
wouldn't have an animal shelter many of
the animals that come in you don't know
if they're vaccinated or not so most of
the animals that come in are getting
surrendered by someone they just drop
them off and leave you don't know if
they had vaccines at the beginning
and there are also a lot of other
disease kennel cough things like that
that looked just like distemper in the
early phases so it's really hard to
differentiate if it's actually the
really dangerous thing that we care
about until it's too late so what we'd
like to know is how do we stop these
rolling outbreaks what kennels within
this intake area are the riskiest or not
riskiest because if we do know the
vaccination status of an animal we can
put them in the high-risk kennels
because they're less likely to get the
disease and we can't have spread that
risk out across the population and
what's changes could we potentially make
to these intake areas that they're using
in order to prevent the spread of the
disease in the first place throughout
these kennels so that was what this
project this case study project is about
the strategy I took because you can
imagine I just said there's no data on
this so what am I gonna do well in the
previous one I took the long run of
trying to generate data collect data
within the environment this one is was a
very immediate problem when it came up
there was actually a December outbreak
at Austin Animal Center and we were
trying to help them with that and so it
was really critical to kind of get some
insights early so what I chose to do
instead of waiting for disease or for
data collection was I chose to try to
come up with a simulation of the Z's now
this is very speculative when you do
something like this but luckily there's
a lot of research into how airborne
diseases work and so I was able to
create the simulation which I'll show
you in a second
improve it by measuring the aggregate
statistics that we were getting out of
AC is - how many animals were showing up
with signs how many of them were dying
all of these different probabilities
that we really wanted to know as well as
doing lit reviews and things like that
to try to pull them out so make the
disease model look more like the disease
we're interested in which is distemper
and then take that model and evaluate
the different human strategies the
veterinarians and other people are
trying to design to modify those intake
areas to tell them which one's probably
the best as well as maybe provide some
other insights that could be useful for
them and then finally and this is the
work in progress is train a
reinforcement learning system to try to
make machine strategies that might be
better than the human strategies so you
know human strategies have the property
of being explainable which is nice but
they often miss a lot of complexity that
could be added in to improve the results
and so if we can give them a machine
design strategy that works better I
think they'd be very happy to use it the
sort of mathematical manifestation of
this problem is a Markov decision
process operating over nodes in a graph
so you can imagine this is sort of the
kennel intake area where each of the
nodes are a kennel each of the edges are
whether or not that kennel can infect to
that other kennel and so this graph
generally if you're talking about a
kennel layout is gonna be a planar graph
unless you're like stacking kennels on
top of each other which they do in some
but I made the assumption that they're
not going to within this intake area
which I don't they generally don't
within the intake area and then you
treat each of these as a node that can
contain a state it can either be empty
have no animal it can have a deceased
animal in it or it can have an animal
with one of the four properties of
either being in susceptible to the
disease susceptible to the disease
infected by the disease but not showing
symptoms or symptomatic so infected and
showing symptoms and then all we need to
define how the disease is gonna spread
throughout these kennels is the
probabilities of the transitions between
these different states there are a
couple of them that are complicated by
the fact that we know that it's an
airborne virus therefore it can spread
potentially more than one hop in the
graph away and so the way that I deal
with that is by defining a function a
kernel function that says the
probability is this for one away this
for two away this for three away etc and
then the last complication is the fact
that actually animals as we've said
become immune after 72 hours and their
immune status actually follows a sort of
saturation curve so over time they
become more and more immune meaning it
becomes less and less probable that they
become infected so if you take all that
put it together which I could have been
showing you these while I was telling
you that when when you define all of
that you have a description now of odd
disease not necessarily a disease we're
talking about but a disease that can
spread throughout an area like this and
then when you simulate it this is just a
disease a random disease that has random
probabilities you get a behavior kind of
like that up at the top so the different
colors are the different states that
we're talking about blue means that they
are susceptible to the infection green
means they're good to go they're in
susceptible yellow means they're
infected but we don't see it orange
means that they're symptomatic black
means it's empty and you'll see a flash
of red which is when one dies and so you
can track these different things over
time and look at sort of what the
behavior the disease is over time as a
particular population flows through a
kennel system like that but as I said
this is for a random disease so we
really want to tune these parameters so
it looks more like distemper so that we
can actually get some insights and now
this disease babes
and the way that we do that is by first
using expert knowledge to fill in what
we can so for instance it turns out in
many of these intake areas the moment
they show symptoms
they get removed and so we know that the
probability of going from symptomatic to
empty is one it happens instantaneously
they may remove them immediately so
there are many of those probabilities
within the connectivity of that Markov
process that we can describe just by
knowing the behavior of our intake area
and then there are a couple like okay
how should the immunity curve look that
we can take from other diseases so it
turns out the distemper I mean
immunologically has a lot in common with
measles so we can actually look at the
measles immunological curve compress it
into the right time and get at least an
approximation so there's some guesswork
involved in that then we got gather
those aggregate statistics so how many
animals after a month should die within
this many animals within this kennel
size what proportion of the animal
should be infected within this
particular time and we can take those
aggregate statistics and try to tune
those parameters to them fortunately we
have those aggregate statistics or
rather unfortunately at AC because of
the outbreak that was going on so I was
able to take sort of after this amount
of time what proportion of the
population should have this property and
use that to try to look for
probabilities that if you run the
simulation for a month produce those
relative proportions of the population
and so you can actually do that it turns
out directly I haven't gotten around to
doing that direct calculation there
there may not be a unique solution but
you can you can do some like polynomial
chains to actually calculate those
directly but you can also more quickly
do something like Bayesian optimization
where you just search the parameter
space of those probabilities until the
result of the simulation fits the
aggregate statistics that you're
interested in which is what I ultimately
did if you haven't used this technique
it's a really nice way to do hyper
parameter tuning and other things that's
a little bit faster than something like
a random search cross-validation has
other uses too so once you have that you
can start testing those human strategies
so human strategies include things like
imagine that you have different rooms
where the animals are so maybe you put
them across four different rooms and you
isolate the the sort of the sections of
your graph computationally into those
rooms so that there's no connections
between the particular in here there's
eight rooms which are each rows so no
connections between rows add animals to
a particular room until it reaches
capacity but then if it doesn't reach
capacity after a day lock the room for
72 hours no other animals go in or out
of that room and then if you need to
overflow you can take
over the next room but that's generally
ill-advised so don't add to animals from
two different days to the same room
that's the key insight this is a
strategy the veterinarians designed and
have actually tested several times but
they don't really know how well it works
another strategy which is a little bit
more effortful but has similar
properties is to treat the whole kennel
graph like a cue and actually feed
animals in it one end and and pull them
out at the other end and every time an
animal gets pulled out you shift them
all down one kennel now of course that
means you have to clean every kennel
every time an animal leaves the system
so you tend to do this in batches but
it's it's an alternate method of doing
this if you can't say have four
different rooms for four different
periods of time so both of these
different human design strategies have
sort of a shared property which is that
space and time are sort of the changes
in space and time for an animal are sort
of locked to each other so if two
animals come in together they're likely
to be adjacent to each other for the
entirety of the duration of their stay
as opposed to what you really don't want
to do is have an animal come in two days
after another animal and then place them
next to each other
because if that first animal was
infected and you didn't know it you've
now given it to an animal who's gonna
stay longer in the system which allows
the disease to persist in the system for
much longer than it would have had you
kept them apart so you really also want
to avoid changing adjacency which that
has the property here none of the
animals are ever next to anyone except
you they came in with so when you run
the simulation on those different human
design strategies you get results that
look a bit like this the basic takeaway
is that that room locking strategy works
really well and it is the best strategy
but it artificially restricts throughput
so as you can imagine if all the rooms
are full you just can't take new animals
and the amounts of animals that make it
through in the sneaking case is actually
greater than the amount that you can
make it in that because on any given day
you have you're restricting the graph to
a subgraph and so if you right if you
have a high variance on that day where
you happen to take in more animals and
you exceed the capacity of that subgraph
then those animals can't be in taked and
so you've restricted the throughput on
that day and an aggregate of over time
across 30 days that means you have taken
fewer animals than you would have
otherwise the sneaking strategy does
work better than random so you could
just do a random strategy play some
wherever so that's good to know is that
she's better than nothing it's very high
effort though so it really would be
better if they had something that
balanced the results of these another
insight that you can get from this is
you can start to look at the graph
theoretic properties of the nodes in
your graph and you might guess this
actually if you just think about sort of
how the disease is spreading and what
his properties are it turns out that the
nodes that if you test across many many
different random graph configurations
the nodes that have a high betweenness
centrality meaning there are more
shortest paths that lead through that
node than other nodes those high
betweenness nodes also have higher
infection probabilities because if you
imagine the disease popping up at a
random point in the graph
it has more of a chance of going through
that node as there is more connectivity
to that node and so this actually
answers that question that we wanted to
know is if you have high risks or lowest
nodes yes it turns out you do and you
can actually measure them without doing
anything but having a graph of your
system which is kind of a nice thing to
take away so then I moved on to trying
to design a machine machine design
strategy this like I said is still a
work in progress turns out to be a very
very hard problem but I used
reinforcement learning to do it I'm
happy to dig in after the talk as to why
reinforcement learning and not other
types of AI learning systems but this is
the basic idea of a reinforcement
learning system the environment is that
kennel graph it's the simulation the
reward in this case is just the
infection rates you have to be very
careful not to give the infection rate
with too high of fidelity the the real
world people don't know when a node is
infected and so this the agent should
not know that the node is infected
either the agent should only have access
to the information that we have in the
real world not like the full admin
access of what's going on in the graph
so the reward is is some proxy for what
the infection rate is the state is some
masked version of that simulation show
them the things a human would get to see
if they were measuring the simulation
and then the action in this case is that
the agent gets to decide how to
rearrange the animals within the kennels
to minimize the spread of the infection
or where to place new animals when they
come into the system so there are many
levels of difficulty in in this problem
you can kind of define it in terms of
what arbitrary variables you're allowing
to change the the most general version
of this would be of an arbitrary graph
any graph and an arbitrary point in time
in the the progression of the outbreak
within your simulation and an arbitrary
state meaning any rearrangement of the
animals
then the agent should be able to make an
optimal choice no matter what those
different configurations are I did make
the choice like I said to make it all
planar graphs you could also lift that
restriction maybe there are stacked
candles when you look at it in run a
bunch of simulations letting all these
things vary you if you start the
simulation from zero animals which is
not common but also not not entirely
uncommon because oftentimes they'll spin
up these intake areas when they start to
notice disease in their population so it
sort of starts from zero you see this
this sort of common disease saturation
curve that'll happen where it
asymptotically approaches a particular
infection rate and that infection rate
just holds sort of indefinitely in the
future and so that's really what we want
to measure is how well you're doing with
that asymptotic infection rate and you
can you can sort of look over time at
what this looks like it is it unfolds
you can also restrict the problem a bit
say okay we're we're really a we maybe
can retrain the algorithm every time
there is a new shelter that has an
outbreak on their graph of whatever
their shelter is that makes it a little
bit easier we don't have to train on any
graph we can restrict it even further
and say well maybe we can retrain for
halfway through this curve so we're
assuming we're gonna get there after
four days we don't have to train for
this beginning part where we're spinning
up the system they'll take our advice
they'll start the thing and then we'll
come in and start giving them a strategy
on day five something like that which
also makes the problem easier and then
finally the problem that I ended up
attempting to solve is take all those
restrictions and then add on to it the
restriction that we're gonna take a
literal single point in time and a
single situation within the graph which
is about as restricted to cases you can
have that's a very it's it's borderline
not useful to be able to do that um
you'd have to retrain the agent
basically every day which is you know
not not ideal but when you do this it
actually turns out to be equivalent to
sorting a list of values where you the
values are probability distributions
that you don't know so you're sampling
the values which is kind of an
interesting math observation so you in
order to train this thing you have to
have a huge amount of observations
it's a stochastic problem so that makes
it even harder it's very sensitive to
those initial conditions which makes it
a somewhat chaotic system I hadn't
proven that and then there are a lot of
edge cases that we know about for
instance if the graph configuration has
all unconnected
bizzy's doesn't spread so we know about
those and there's probably a bunch of
education we don't know about so this
low-level problem is still really hard
and like I said is equivalent to sorting
sort of a bunch of unknown values which
is a solvable problem but not easy to
solve and so I took my shot at solving
that version of the problem after
realizing I wasn't gonna solve any of
those top ones and actually was able to
train an agent that was able to tie the
best human strategy which in this
particular case I eliminated the room
locking because it's sort of cheating
you're allowing yourself to not take in
animals which is not the reality of the
situation and so trained against the
snake versus the random and was able to
tie the the trick in training this thing
is a lot of times it likes to do nothing
over doing something seemingly that
works better and I think the reason is
because it's so easy to do something
that makes it worse because of those
properties we talked about earlier which
is that if you change the adjacency of
two animals then you're more likely to
spread the disease more and so the
actual choices you make have to be very
careful and verified - so training
something like this is not easy and I
think really the limitations here are a
lot more computational power I was just
running this on my local computer and
anyone who's done reinforcement learning
knows you benefit a lot from being able
to run it several million times and not
several tens of thousands of times and
then also just sort of a better
understanding of some of those other
sort of onion layered versions of the
problem so a lot more to talk about
there but let's move on cuz I've got ten
minutes to go over one more thing which
is this sort of high-level
problem-solving oriented approach to how
shelters work in general so shelters in
the u.s. they're about 13,000 known
rescues and shelters in the US alone
they serve we think somewhere between
six and eight million animals a year
shelters are really just designed to
serve as many animals as possible as
efficiently as possible and they're
constantly overwhelmed and so many of
them don't know what data to write down
they don't have time to figure it out
they kind of write down everything or
nothing or somewhere in between more or
less at random and they don't really
know the best way of measuring their
success and doing so in a way that when
they develop a strategy that works for a
certain population like we have with
parvo or with some of these other things
they don't know how to share those
solutions with other shelters
effectively because they're not all
talking the same language in terms of
how they're measuring their their
success so really there's no
standardization of data no
standardization of
api's or the ability to create those
things and measure their success and
then share those ideas and so the as
many of you probably are imagining right
now there's lots of ways you can address
these problems you just have to have the
time and the know-how to do so and so
the sort of strategies that I took were
designing things like critical data
templates so here's the list of 10
things that if you're only gonna write
down 10 things write down these 10
things because they're the ones that are
going to get you the most answers
provide recommendations given those 10
things for different metrics they can
measure there's this issue with an idea
called good hearts law in here which is
that if you give them just sort of a
single top level KPI or even two they're
gonna find a ways to min max those
without actually solving the problem and
this is true of every organization
top-level KPIs are very risky and
they're a good way to trap yourself in a
bad practices because you want to
maximize that number at all cost without
actually thinking about your mission
so that's tricky and then most
importantly provide a tool that allows
them to do all these things very easily
and then link that tool and its results
when it gives you a result back to
documentation so that other shelters can
self serve on these things and come up
with what are their problems and what
are their solutions without even needing
to reach out to anyone make it as fast
and easy as possible so as you can
imagine data templates there's a bunch
of ways to do these most of these
shelters use various versions of Google
tools and so giving them a template in
Google sheets that allows them to know
what all of the critical values are and
if they're categorical what categorical
values that we would recommend they use
and then providing interfaces to common
databases that allow them to convert
their data into a standardized formats
that's the strategy I ended up taking
standardizing the KPIs there's a lot of
different critical KPIs and I think
actually providing a view into a dozen
or so of them is really helpful as long
as those dozen or so abstract out to
solution documentation and so I built
actually a first version of the
dashboard using a combination of tools
that was designed to be able to be spun
up and run sort of locally and/or or to
be in a web presence if you're willing
to spend up the server-side stuff and
allow them to create these little
printable interactive dashboards where
they can save a copy of it distribute it
in an HTML file to whoever they want and
link to the documentation as appropriate
so that was the prototype for that
American pencil lives as an organization
is entirely about this problem and so
they were
excited that someone had like a tech
thing that would make it easier for them
and so we very quickly prototype it with
eight different shelters who were able
to run their data through it's um we
found all sorts of different issues with
in particular cause of death is really
the critical thing and they're right
because you want to save them from that
and most shelters don't have a good way
of logging cause of death consistently
so that's still an open problem we did
find after a while people didn't want to
deal with sort of local python or even
server Python code maintenance and so
creating a easy to maintain version of
this became the next step which is just
basically poured all those figures over
to a Google cloud version of that using
Google Data studio this seems to be the
preferred solution for many people it's
it's fairly feature-rich it doesn't
scale super well and if you're like
Dallas and you take in you know thirty
forty thousand dogs a year this doesn't
perform super well it's probably still
better than anything that they have
right now but I think there's probably
gonna be somewhere somewhere to meet in
the middle between those solutions that
that's gonna work best as you saw at the
beginning I sort of throw multiple tools
at these problems because I know that
not all of them are going to stick and
if you put all your eggs in one basket
you're just gonna lose and so then we
have documentation for some of these
problems this is the parvo documentation
it's a public wiki that says literally
everything you need to know about how to
treat parvo so we can link that into
there one thing that we haven't done
though is add automatic decision-making
processes for them to help them find out
diagnose their issues and then link out
to these documents so we give them sort
of the dashboard and then we give them
the list of solutions but we don't have
a good link between the two yet but the
combination of these things I hope in
the in the coming weeks and months will
mean that shelters will be more unable
to self serve on this problem of how do
I serve my population better okay so
coming back to the key takeaways those
are the the three topics I wanted to
talk with you all about and and really
that the dump you know as cool as that
technology is the thing I would like you
to take away from this talk is all of
that stuff of stuff I did in my free
time and I did it for fun and it was
super satisfying and super interesting
and if you have find yourself with free
time and you want to do a cool tech
project there are so many nonprofits in
town that you could help out and they
don't know that they need help
and so you need to reach out to them if
there's a an issue that you care about
if there's a problem that you're in
sit in find an organization in Austin
find a national organization reach out
to them and offer to help and they'll
say sure and then you'll have to set up
four different meetings because they're
gonna cancel three of them and that
eventually you're gonna get to where you
understand their problem and you can
work autonomously on that problem and
you can deliver them for tools where
they pick one and and they'll use it and
honestly the satisfaction you're gonna
get out of out of following something
like this is is so is so excellent that
I really I want everyone to do it if
they if they have the time and the
interest I do want to thank some of my
collaborators who helped me out with the
various projects and and some of the
data analytics and helping me get the
data and I want to thank you all for
your time
[Applause]
so I think we only have a couple minutes
for questions but I'd love to answer any
questions you have yeah
data from filters to data from what no
so this is something I would love to be
able to do that offices are almost
always private businesses and I'm not
sure how to give them get them to give
up any data I actually think a lot of
them would be down to do it with the
right like data use agreements in place
so where they feel protected but there's
such a huge financial and liability risk
to them there is for other shelters but
there's more of a standard in even in
private so APA is a private shelter as
opposed to a AC which is the city run
shelter the city run shelter has legal
mandates that actually just got passed a
month or so ago that they must share
data APA chooses to share data but it's
actually a risk for APA to do that
because people like to attack shelters
it's a very hot button issue and
everyone loves to attack each other in
that space and so I think private
practices would be very reticent to do
anything like that but I would love to
do it with them if they'd be interested
yeah so I started the parvo efforts
started as in like I started pitching it
to people and trying to get people
interested in it in probably 2014 when I
started my PhD it took maybe two years
before I got my first piece of data out
of that I built a lot of tools along the
way
actually that's not sure I built many of
the tools I talked about in the very
beginning starting in 2011 the moment I
got there I saw they needed a scheduling
tool they needed a end of shift report
those sorts of things the distemper one
I started about a year and a half ago
but I haven't worked on it in several
months the kpi's one though I think I
only started about six months ago and
many of these things I find happen in
very quick sprints like you you start
working on it you make a lot of progress
in about a month two months and then it
just sort of goes away for six months
and then it comes back up and the key is
to be open to it coming back up and not
just abandoning something because you're
not making progress on it and if you
have enough projects going on at the
same time you're always going to be
making progress on something yeah
mm-hmm
yeah so on the I'll do the data one
first so the question was how did you
get the data and did you have to work
with them to get accurate data input
into a system so some of the tools that
I built like the end of shift report are
forms that they fill out and so data
accuracy obviously you're worried about
people having an incentive to enter the
data accurately on those the incentive
is actually that every day when people
are about to come into the shift they
look at the output of that form which
gets published somewhere and they say oh
how long am I gonna have to expect to be
on this volunteer shift so the everyone
who uses that particular data entry
mechanism also is incentivized to look
at the results which creates a nice
closed-loop incentive for them to
interact your data on the treatment
sheets side I actually do think the data
accuracy could improve because those
you're taking that I think I showed it
at some point an image of a treatment
sheet and then inputting rows for every
column that's in that treatment sheet
and we actually were able to get funding
after a little bit to hire a new
veterinary technician who in their free
time while they were doing their normal
vet tech work spent time doing data
entry on those things we actually now
have a big data set of pictures of those
treatment sheets and I think it'd be
awesome to have a computer vision
approach to automatically input those so
that if there are biases in our input
approach at least they're consistent
because humans are very inconsistent or
to otherwise crowdsource the entry of
that information I think we can do a lot
better on that front and as we collect
more and more data 800 samples a year
where we already have the biggest parvo
dataset in the world we're gonna have
the biggest by two orders of magnitude
soon and so I think that would be great
on the cat's issue the article that I
linked to earlier I actually highlight
the disparity between cats and dogs and
how we talk about them and then
culturally within the shelter system in
that article if you look at like a
Google search frequency for dog adoption
versus cat adoption cats are like a
third consistently of searches for dogs
if you look at adoption records you find
that people who adopt cats are way more
likely to adopt the second cats people
who adopt dogs are more likely to just
opt one there's a lot of asymmetries in
in that system for these diseases
distemper does not have great analog for
cats but parvo does it's called pan luke
and we actually in the paarvai so you
treat both so we have kittens who come
in with pan luke and we treat them and
we haven't looked a lot at the data yet
so I do think there's a lot of cool
openings to do that we are working on a
study right now on animal bonding
specifically in cats and cats
have particular conditions like
paralysis or diabetes that requires a
lot of maintenance does that create a
tighter bond with their with their owner
so I think there's a lot of unique
problems in cats that we're starting to
try to address but there's a weird
cultural asymmetry in how much effort we
put into cats versus how much effort we
put into dogs that I don't think
anyone's quite gotten their their head
around yet so now we're at a time I
don't know if we have time for one more
question
are there any one more question maybe
nope okay thank you very much
[Applause]